cruella is the story of how the puppy
kidnapping fashionista first
introduced in 101 dalmatians fell into a
life of villainy the film captures a
bygone era in a chaotic but appealing
way
which will suit viewers who understand
how different things used to be
these are the things only adults will
notice in cruella
it's far from the first disney movie to
do this but adults in the audience will
notice that cruella slips in a few
grown-up vices for its characters
it's not the first time disney has done
this 101 dalmatians beauty and the beast
sleeping beauty and the great mouse
detective
all classic disney films each have
scenes depicting the consumption of
alcohol
also who could forget the infamously
trippy pink elephant montage from dumbo
after the pint-sized pachyderm
accidentally ingests some hooch
throughout cruella we see several
characters enjoying fancy cocktails at
parties and liquid lunches
alcohol is the only vice the film sees
fit to include
gone is the sinister cigarette holder
cruella deville's animated version
carried it would have made sense to show
smoking both for character consistency
and for the setting
smoking was far more common in the 1970s
and is still associated with the fashion
industry to this day
walt disney himself was a fan of tobacco
a truth the company has tried to wipe
from history by editing cigarettes out
of his hands in old photos
kids probably won't notice either the
presence of alcohol or the absence of
smoking but both of these things will be
more conspicuous to adults
[Music]
it's a cliche that if there is a parent
in a disney film they are most likely
not going to see their kids graduation
from simba's father to lilo's parents
and bambi's mom
if you produce life within the disney
universe your odds of meeting an
untimely demise are much higher than
normal
it's become such a trope that in many
parodies of the disney formula the fate
of the main character's parents is now a
standard running joke
disney despite its squeaky clean
reputation often also has the villains
and their stories meet their end in
rather sickening fashion
from bill sykes being hit by a train and
oliver and company to the hunchback of
notre dame
disney has racked up quite the body
count true to form cruella utilizes its
pg-13 rating and opts to lean into this
cliche of parental death with gusto
a young cruella known then as estella
sees her mother meet her end during the
first act of the film
we see estella chased from a fancy party
by angry dalmatians who end up knocking
her poor mother off a cliff
this definitely ranks as one of the
grizzlier ways a disney character has
been shuffled off the mortal coil
especially in recent memory any kids who
see cruella will be in for an education
on a genre of music that adults are
already familiar with
punk rock punks started breaking into
the mainstream in the mid to late 70s
giving voice to a burgeoning revolution
against the more excessive style of
mainstream music at the time
the punk bands prevalent during this era
operated under a diy mentality
often self-producing and distributing
their music independently
the movement gained traction in the
united states with the likes of the
ramones
and the united kingdom with groups like
the sex pistols it was counterculture
politically charged and in your face
it's also a key factor in the plot and
style of the film especially cruella
fighting back against the upper class
through
aggressively charged art the uk's punk
rock revolution serves as the backdrop
for cruella's rise to prominence
and the film takes full advantage of it
visually cruella shown in a quickly
paced montage
stages several raucous public reveals of
her twisted new fashion line she not
only utilizes motorcycles and a garbage
truck but goes as far
as to stage a punk rock fashion show
right outside her arch rivals event
the choice to set the film in such an
important era for fashion and music is a
clever one
the chaotic nature of the music and the
visuals suits cruella and her ever
escalating mix of insanity and
theatricality
adults are far more likely to appreciate
the time capsule
aspect of cruella and its use of one of
art's most tumultuous eras
disney is no stranger to cartoonish
madness from maleficent
and sleeping beauty to ursula in the
little mermaid disney has crafted some
of pop culture's most
memorable and watchable villains
although these characters have fans of
all ages
truly committed supporters tend to be
adults who often have a deeper
understanding of on-screen evildoers
complex
motivations and psychologies case in
point cruella has two completely
distinct selves
adults will understand how this
fractured psyche symbolized by the
half-black half-white color of her hair
impacts cruella's behavior that's ugly
that's cool
my name's estella not cruella first
there's estella
a mildly sassy but hopelessly klutzy hot
mess who's happy to stay in her lane
then there's her less relatable side
cruella a flamboyant chaotically
self-obsessed schemer
with grand plans for mayhem when
presented with the central conflict a
stella is forced behind the curtain
while cruella takes center stage
adults will also pick up on cultural
context the dividing cruella's
personality is in the tradition of
scores of classic stories such as dr
jekyll and mr hyde
fans might also see echoes of dc villain
two-face who like cruella has an outward
appearance that reflects an inner
duality
the movie's story draws on the fickle
nature of the fashion industry but
cruella doesn't stop at just the
internal workings of the business
the film also has a bit to say about how
brands use the media to alter public
perception
introduced early in the film is
cruella's childhood friend anita darling
who in adulthood has become a journalist
immediately recognizing anita as her
former classmate cruella is eager to
enter into a unique business arrangement
with her
taking advantage of their connection
cruella coaxes anita into giving her
forthcoming public takedown of the
baroness's fashion line a boost in terms
of coverage
the media has often been used to shape
people's perspectives and perceptions
for the benefit of those looking to sell
a product this is obviously far from
exclusive to the fashion industry
examples exist in almost every industry
that said it's a particularly important
aspect of fashion
and cruella does a wickedly good job of
showcasing its utility
adults will pick up on the concepts of
brand awareness demographics and the
manner in which the media
talks to consumers meanwhile younger
kids will more than likely watch the
movie in blissful ignorance with regards
to these themes
kids don't perceive fashion the same way
that adults do as
it's an industry built on what's hot
versus what's not words like reinventing
and trends pop up quite frequently in
the discussion around fashion and for
good reason
they are the backbone of an industry in
which designers depend on their ability
to churn out
exciting new looks on a regular basis in
cruella we see estella constantly
innovating with bizarre designs which
end up catching the eye of the baroness
this of course results in a stella
learning just how cut throat to the
baroness and by extension the entire
fashion industry truly is
i'll just have to destroy her as we have
so many before find her
the film has a lot in common with the
devil wears prada another movie that
uses the toxic side of fashion in its
story
both films follow an unpolished rookie
working in the footsteps of a heinously
conceited fashion mentor
in the devil wears prada the rookie is
anne hathaway and the mentor is meryl
streep and their dynamic isn't all that
dissimilar to the one between cruella
and the baroness in cruella the major
differences between the two films lie in
their tones and styles of execution
the devil wears prada is a more
down-to-earth modern narrative about
what happens when you lose sight of who
you really are
meanwhile cruella is more stylized and
has a lot to say about identity as well
as embracing your inner dark side
the toxic and cutthroat underbelly of
the fashion industry plays a big part in
cruella but it's aimed squarely at the
adults in the audience
it'll fly over the heads of kids who are
only concerned with whether or not their
shoes have velcro laces
ever since it was announced cruella de
vil would be getting her own movie the
internet has been saturated with
comments
labeling the film as a girl boss joker
since the release of joker in 2019 any
film or show that portrays a person's
steady unraveling into villainy and
violence has been compared to it
it's a story that started being told far
earlier than joker
a couple of earlier examples both
involving joker co-stars robert de niro
our taxi driver and
king of comedy still joaquin phoenix's
performance earned him an oscar so it
stands to reason that people would see
echoes of joker in movies that followed
in its wake
cruella and joker protagonist arthur
fleck definitely share some similarities
in the way they are presented in their
respective films both had unpleasant
childhoods which resulted in grim
adulthoods that found them grappling
with instability as well as unpleasant
lines of work additionally they both
have a moment within their films that
can be seen as a sort of coming out
arthur debuting his joker persona on
murray franklin's show and
estella debuting her cruella persona at
the baronesses party
one visual similarity the films share is
how as the main character's mental state
begins to degrade and their world
becomes more chaotic
the world around them becomes more
vibrant it's a smart way of displaying
change and one that shows just how happy
both characters are when they're
indulging in their chaotic sides
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff for coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you